[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportages sur Public Sénat 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité grâce
à nos experts et voici le sommaire de ce
30 mai le gouvernement et les
républicains vont-ils vraiment négocier
autour de la loi immigration hier le
ministre de l'Intérieur leur tendait la
main les présidents de groupe au Sénat
et à l'Assemblée ne l'ont pas vraiment
saisi ils font des régularisations des
étrangers travaillant pour les métiers
en tension une ligne rouge à ne pas
franchir on y reviendra dans notre
premier débat 100% politique et puis
juste après on fait le bilan d'un
festival de Cannes très polémique et
très politique il a commencé par la
critique contre la présence sur le tapis
rouge de Johnny Depp l'acteur accusé de
violences conjugales le délégué général
du festival a justifié son choix
je ne connais pas l'image de Johnny Depp
aux États-Unis pour vous dire la vérité
nous on voit un film
vous savez dans la moi j'ai une seule
conduite dans la vie c'est la liberté de
penser la liberté de parler la liberté
d'agir dans le cadre de la loi un
festival de Cannes qui s'est clos sur la
palme d'or de la réalisatrice française
Justine Triet elle a fustigé je cite un
gouvernement néolibéral qui casse notre
exception culturelle la charge est-elle
injuste on en débattra aussi avec nos
invités tout à l'heure mais d'abord le
baromètre odoxa mascara de ce mois de
mai pour Public Sénat et la presse
régionale nous avons choisi d'interroger
les citoyens français sur les violences
faites aux élus faut-il durcir l'arsenal
législatif première réponse avec Audrey
vetaz
en sortant de sa réunion avec Elisabeth
borne Yannick Morez le maire
démissionnaire de Saint-Brevin avait un
souhait que son départ à la suite de
graves pression et d'un incendie
criminel à son domicile fassent changer
les choses pour les autres mères je
pense que ça va ça va bouger il y avait
également donc tout à l'heure le
président de l'association des mains de
France qui était là donc non je pense
que voilà ça va faire bouger les choses
les choses bouge en tout cas dans
l'esprit des Français 63% d'entre eux
pensent que la sécurité des mers n'est
pas bien assurée en France et ils sont
80% à être favorables au renforcement
des sanctions pour violences contre des
élus et cela pourrait se transcrire
rapidement dans la loi un texte vient
d'être déposé au Sénat il prévoit
notamment de sanctionner plus lourdement
les auteurs de violences contre les élus
comme c'est déjà le cas pour les
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique autre piste renforcer le lien
entre les mers et les préfets et des
mieux les élus victimes de violence
des cas bénévole disons les choses
c'est-à-dire qu'elles sont et bien il
faut pouvoir l'accompagner par les
conseils d'un avocat par les procédure
civiles les procédures pénales c'est par
contre normal et que le préfet qui a des
moyens que les mers n'ont pas et bien
puissent apporter ce soutien
d'effectible au maire naturellement
lorsque le maire est victime la
proposition de loi devrait être examinée
à l'automne prochain
trois grands thèmes dans ce débat 100%
politique les violences contre les élus
la proposition de loi du groupe liotte à
l'Assemblée pour détricoter la réforme
des retraites et puis les éventuels
négociations entre le gouvernement et
les républicains sur la loi immigration
et j'accueille Gaëlle Slimane bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes président et
cofondateur dodoxa uncharlenbe bonsoir
bienvenue constitutionnalisme Bruno
cotreize bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue à
vous politologues chercheurs au CNRS et
au sevy-pof avec nous en duplex j'accue
également Yves Sancy Seigneur Partners
chez mascara vous scruter les réseaux
sociaux pour ce baromètre bienvenue à
vous et Emily zappalski bonsoir Émilie
spécialiste en communication politique
éditorialiste pour sens publique je
commence avec notre baromètre Gael
Slimane on a vu certains éléments déjà
grâce à Audrey que disent les citoyens
français qu'est-ce qui selon vous est le
plus marquant dans dans ce baromètre sur
les violences faites synthétisé mais
dans le dans le sujet qu'on vient de
voir vous le savez les maires sont les
élus préféré des Français ce sont les
seuls finalement qui trouvent réellement
grâce à leurs yeux et les Français sont
convaincus que globalement il y a pas
spécialement besoin de renforcer la
sécurité de tous les autres élus les
députés et les sénateurs c'est pas la
peine c'est ça les les personnes les
permanences des députés c'est pas la
même en revanche on peut voir on peut
voir les chiffres on peut les donner
pardon je vous laisse continuer mais
c'est député
à 70% selon les Français résidences
personnelles 57% permanence des députés
56% mais exceptions voilà exception sur
les élus locaux les deux tiers en gros
des Français 63% nous disent bah non la
sécurité de ces gens-là elle n'est pas
assurée on le voyait aussi dans votre
sujet on est sur des élus à qui on
demande beaucoup qui sont alors on aime
cette expression en politique parfois
des présidents qui sont assez
à lointaines distance du public le plus
souvent disent je vais mettre à porter
d'engueulade le maire il est apporté
d’engueulades tout le temps et
malheureusement comme on l'a vu pour le
maire de Saint-Brévin bien ça dépasse
l'engueulade et ça dépasse les bornes et
donc les Français nous disent j'ai
conscience de ce problème il faut
renforcer leur sécurité et deuxièmement
ça enlève très clairement vu dans le
dans le sujet il nous disent aussi nous
sommes favorables à un durcissement des
sanctions 80 % à 80 % et il y a
formidable consensus qui règne dans
l'opinion qu'on soit de droite de gauche
du centre tout le monde est
majoritairement d'accord si on veut être
taquin on relèvera que ceux qui sont
parfois les plus virulents c'est à dire
les sympathisants insoumis sont les
moins nombreux à être favorables à ce
durcissement des sanctions mais même eux
sont une majorité elle souhaitait Bruno
Contrex ça vous surprend pas trop ce
petit bémol du côté de des sympasisants
et les filles non pas vraiment parce que
c'est un électorat qui est très sensible
à la question du tout sécuritaire quel
sentiment que le tour est précis le tout
sécuritaire n'est jamais la solution à
apporter et qu'il faut faire de la
pédagogie qu'il faut miser sur les
valeurs de la citoyenneté donc c'est pas
tellement étonnant effectivement de les
voir un tout petit peu en dessous mais
effectivement Gaëlle vient de le
rappeler ils sont quand même
majoritaires en sondage à vouloir en
renforcement des des sanctions contre
les élus et on a un niveau de moyenne de
l'ensemble des échantillons qui est de
toute façon tellement importante ça veut
dire que c'est dans toutes les
catégories sociales et catégories
politiques et on reviendra sur cette
idée de d'élus apporter d'engueulade
dans un instant mais un Charlen Bizan je
voudrais que vous nous éclairiez que dit
notre droit notre arsenal législatif en
la matière est-ce qu'on est plus ou
moins
une armée pour réprimer les violences
faites aux élus par rapport à nos
voisins européens alors paradoxalement
par rapport à ce qui ressort dans les
faits on n'est pas si mal loti d'un
point de vue législatif le code pénal en
réalité à 6000 beaucoup les élus avec
des délits droits communs donc c'est
pareil pour l'outrage les attentats à la
personne etc ou il peut même y avoir une
circonstance aggravante lorsqu'on s'en
prend directement à un élu et il y a
même la création depuis peu notamment
une loi de 2021 de délices spécifiques
alors c'est pas uniquement les élus mais
c'est les élus et ceux qui portent
notamment un uniforme et bien d'outrage
de menaces etc qui sont déjà punies
assez lourdement 45000 euros d'amende
jusqu'à 3 ans d'emprisonnement donc j'ai
pas le sentiment que ce soit tant
l'arsenal législatif qui soit faible que
finalement la réponse pénale qui est
donnée mais pour beaucoup de faiblesses
c'est-à-dire déjà les élus peinent à
dénoncer ces atteintes parce que il y a
déjà un énorme problème d'identification
ça peut se passer sur les réseaux à
partir de quand ça devient une vraie
menace à partir de pas grave c'est un
curseur aussi que les élus ont parfois
eu du mal à mener que les préfets
eux-mêmes ont parfois dénigré on le voit
avec l'exemple du maire de Saint-Brévin
donc il y a une question de prévention
qui est pas forcément bien assurée et il
y a aussi une réponse pénale qui est pas
à la hauteur parce que quand bien même
on arrive finalement à avoir un coupable
et bien les peines sont pas à la hauteur
des maximum légaux donc on voit bien
qu'en fait c'est pas tant l'arsenal
c'est la réponse qu'il y a un peu bon
après tout c'est normal c'est des élus
c'est normal qu'ils s'assembler de temps
en temps
une question aussi de d'élus qui sont un
petit peu démunies par rapport à la
charge de travail ce qui était dit dans
le reportage c'est à dire qu'il se
débrouille souvent seuls ils sont
souvent des bénévoles souvent dans des
territoires ruraux un petit peu pas
abandonnés mais en tout cas à faire
beaucoup beaucoup de choses et on a
l'impression que c'est une des
difficultés du gouvernement de prendre
en compte tous ces territoires ruraux il
y avait le périurbain avec les gilets
jaunes les ruraux il y a un plan réalité
qui doit naître mais on voit bien que ça
a du mal à prendre vraiment en forme
d'ailleurs technique fort qui est aux
avant-garde pour ça donc j'ai
l'impression que c'est aussi cette
problématique là de ces élus qui sont si
appréciées parce que c'est comme des
voisins c'est des personnalités de la
vie du village de la vie et en fait il
manque d'ingénierie pour développer leur
propre projet comment ils peuvent être
conseillés pour à titre préventif à
titre juridique ou titre de sécurité ça
je pense qu'il va falloir un petit peu
mettre passer la seconde on peut dire ça
comme ça avec on a un peu évoqué une
peut-être une sous-estimation du
phénomène justement avec
l'intériorisation dont on parlait
écoutez justement celui qui a relancé le
débat en annonçant sa démission le maire
de Saint-Brevin sur ce thème
et le chiffre est donné c'est ce que
j'ai dit la première ministre est
totalement sous-évalué
de façon il n'y a rien qui suit derrière
et donc c'est un sujet important c'est
agression vis-à-vis des élus le
gouvernement a pris des mesures dans un
premier temps
ça sera à nous de les élus il vient de
voir si ça va jusqu'au bout si elles
sont suffisantes donc il nous dit
augmentation de 32% des agressions
vis-à-vis des mers et chiffres
sous-évalués beaucoup de mer ne déposent
plus plainte ils sont si je viens vers
vous une première fois pour nous
éclairer sur les réactions sur ce thème
des violences aux élus sur les réseaux
les médias sociaux comment c'est perçu
est-ce que c'est perçu comme un fait
divers comme les autres ou au contraire
circonstances aggravante on en parlait
dites nous oui la question la question
est là comme le disait Gaëlle le disiez
tous le maire a une un statut
particulier d'abord les mers sont tous
connus de leurs administrés souvent
contrairement à d'autres élus notamment
dans les grandes agglomérations mais sur
ce phénomène là c'est c'est le sort de
Yannick Morez qui a fait réagir c'est à
dire dès le 11 mai je crois qu'il y a eu
une émotion liée à ce qu'il a lui-même
vécu et qu'il a raconté en tant qu'
bienveillance et donc ça a provoqué un
vrai tourbillon médiatique on parle de
d'augmentation des mentions et de ce
qu'on appelle les engagements
c'est-à-dire où les gens disent j'aime
pas je suis ému c'est 830 000
engagements d'un seul coup c'est
vraiment beaucoup par contre
je crois qu'il y a une identification
sur le thème de la sécurité
et ce qu'on a vu très rapidement dans
les jours qui ont suivi c'est ce qu'on
appelle le format fait divers c'est à
dire
consommer et ensuite évacuer donc on
peut dire que ça n'a pas eu
véritablement de suite
c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'émotion du fait du vert et je ne suis
pas persuadé que les internautes et donc
les Français les prix comme un phénomène
touchant spécifiquement les élus mais
comme une expression de la violence
sociale ça commence c'est très
intéressant on peut dire malheureusement
c'est ça a pas forcément lancé sur les
réseaux sociaux les médias sociaux un
débat de société autour du statut des
élus de et des violences qu'il subissent
Bruno cotress on l'a dit ils sont en
première ligne mais est-ce qu'on peut
dire aussi qu'ils prennent pour les
autres élus ceux qui sont plus loin
alors c'est pas impossible effectivement
qui prennent pour les autres il y a
d'ailleurs pas que les mers il y a les
conseils municipaux aussi autant le
nombre de démissions de mer est à peu
près stable par contre chez les
conseillers municipaux alors là c'est
vraiment très forte augmentation donc on
voit effectivement l'ensemble du
personnel politique qui est exposé
effectivement alors les maires on vient
la rappeler tout à l'heure ils sont à
porter ils sont apportés d'engueulade
donc ils prennent peut-être un peu cher
pour les autres effectivement de ce
point de vue là
je pense aussi que par rapport à ce qui
vient d'être dit sur les éléments
d'identification
forcément un maire et en particulier
celui-ci avec c'est un maire au fond
dans sa commune il est proche des
Français lui-même c'est un médecin donc
quelqu'un qui exerce une une profession
qui est une profession du soin qui est
une profession qui met en contact avec
la vie de tous les jours là on parle
vraiment voilà
sont très forts et je pense
qu'effectivement derrière cet élément
d'identification ça va bien au-delà et
ça parle aux yeux de l'opinion à un
sentiment beaucoup plus difficile
beaucoup plus général quel sentiment un
peu d'une perte des repères un peu
généralisé c'est à dire que les
autorités qui s'agissent d'une autorité
un peu morale comme le maire ou le
médecin du village les autorités qui
s'agissent des policiers également ne
sont plus respectés dans leur fonction
et ce sentiment est très diffus et lui
par contre il s'est installé de manière
extrêmement ancrée du rap dans l'opinion
le Sénat est en première ligne pour
mieux aider les mers éventuellement
durcir la loi c'est pas une surprise
faut peut-être là aussi faire un peu de
pédagogie on adore ça ici c'est la
chambre des territoires donc ce lien il
est il est réel et on va le toucher du
doigt aussi lors des prochaines
élections sénatoriales il faut expliquer
tout ça en quelques mots
que le Sénat est en effet le
représentant des territoires en réalité
c'est pas tout à fait la même
représentation que l'Assemblée nationale
qui est la représentation du peuple
souverain dans dans toute sa dans toute
sa généralité donc oui le Sénat a
d'ailleurs une priorité législative en
ce qui concerne les collectivités
territoriales donc c'est la chambre on
va dire la plus attendue sur ces
questions et notamment la plus
sensibilisée parce que évidemment
beaucoup de sénateurs viennent de
carrière rurales d'ailleurs on en a
parlé c'est-à-dire même vraiment de
localité profonde donc connaissent bien
et ressentent bien cette précarité
notamment par rapport aux violences je
trouve qu'on a un point intéressant
aussi qui a été développé dans ce que
nous a dit Monsieur Sancy c'est que en
réalité il y a un phénomène fait divers
c'est à dire qu'on voit bien que c'est
l'émotionnel qui a parlé ici et donc
finalement ça va amener à un engagement
politique mais on se rend compte que
pour arriver à lancer un renouveau de la
législation et c'est ce qu'on disait
avec le manque de moyens le manque de
pédagogie etc il faut avant tout que
cette réaction ait lieu donc ce
baromètre est bon signe c'est-à-dire que
du coup il nous prouve que l'opinion est
aujourd'hui assez mûre prête par rapport
justement à ce phénomène
d'identification pour éventuellement une
modification de la législation et pour
mieux comprendre ce phénomène qu'il faut
le rappeler certes à des évolutions
récentes mais quand même assez ancré
assez ancien beaucoup d'émissions de
merde beaucoup d'émissions de jeunes
élus donc la politique séduit moins par
rapport à cette violence mais
aujourd'hui le peuple est prêt à
comprendre aussi ce que ça signifie en
terme voilà peut-être plus humain un mot
de conclusion là-dessus ensuite on passe
au secondaire parce que là on est sur le
volet le volet sécurité mais unchard l'a
très bien dit le sujet derrière c'est à
quel point ça fait envie à des gens
capables compétents pour une
rémunération qui en 95% des cas est bien
en deçà de l'investissement ou ce qu'il
pourrait gagner dans le privé comme on
dit à quel point ça c'est la goutte
d'eau qui fait déborder qui fait
déborder le vase et qui peut inciter des
gens qui ont des vocations qui ont envie
de donner de leur temps et des
emmerdements pour dire les choses
clairement à quel point ça peut les
dissuader et moi j'ai peur de cet effet
goutte d'eau et vous avez raison un
challenge je pense que l'opinion
publique elle va peut-être pas
manifester dans les rues pour défendre
ses élus tous les jours mais le fait
qu'elle vous voyez tous les signaux à
travers cette étude et sans doute
d'autres de tous les feux verts en
disant on est presque vous agissiez pour
les protéger je pense que c'est
important je me souviens plus c'est pas
une colle Bruno mais au dernier
élections municipales il y a eu beaucoup
de de ville de petites villes enfin de
villerupturale où il y avait pas de
candidats où on arrivait pas finalement
à mobiliser
pour pouvoir organiser tout simplement
une élection avec des mers qui étaient
obligés de rester en poste parce que oui
il y a eu effectivement et ça a été pas
mal souligné par les études qu'on a
réalisé il y a eu aussi beaucoup de
mères qui disaient ne plus vouloir se
représenter à un nouveau mandat
exprimer exprimer une forme de
l'Institut à la fois par les
responsabilités de plus en plus
écrasante au fond mais aussi le
sentiment d'être face à des administrés
qui ne sont pas assez reconnaissants le
sentiment que au fond il mouille leurs
chemises effectivement il a raison dans
la plupart des communes pour une
rémunération extrêmement symbolique on
parle pas du tout des élus des grandes
villes ça c'est vraiment une notre
population d'élus mais on l'immense
majorité ce sont des toutes petites
communes ils n'en touche quasiment une
indemnité que que symbolique et par
contre le sentiment à la fois de devoir
gérer beaucoup de responsabilités
potentiellement pénale plus plus un
absence de reconnaissance voire des
engueulades en permanence y compris si
on refuse un permis de construire si on
met une contravention par la police
municipale dites à vos maires de temps
en temps que vous êtes contents aussi
enfin voilà si je peux faire passer un
message tendance à mettre même des
messages c'est vrai pour tout quand on
est mécontent un service dites-leur que
vous êtes content Thomas c'est juste que
je voulais dire c'est que on fait
beaucoup dans les institutions d'âge
d'études municipales et puis on mesure
aussi au niveau national toutes les
communes pour lesquelles on travaille
qui n'avait pas fait d'études près de
sondage préalablement sont étonnés en
voyant les résultats en disant 75% 80%
de satisfaction 85% de jugement positifs
sur l'action du maire mais c'est pas
possible vous vous sentez ces chiffres
mais non mais en réalité les gens ne
viennent jamais vous voir taper à la
porte pour venir au fait on est très
content bravo les gens viennent vous
voir pour aller pour critiquer pour
aller mais c'est bon de le rappeler
quand même que le plus souvent on est
satisfait voilà et le message est passé
deuxième thème de notre débat comme
promis cette proposition de loi à
l'Assemblée nationale pour abroger le
report de l'âge légal à 64 ans Quentin
calmé peut nous rejoindre bonsoir
Quentin le gouvernement qui sent monter
la pression autour de ce texte venu du
groupe Biot voilà le groupe liote on va
le rappeler hein c'est un petit groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale avec beaucoup
d'élus centriste Corse ou ultramarins un
petit groupe mais qui a réussi à
coaliser la quasi-totalité des
oppositions gouvernement et d'ailleurs
je voulais vous montrer une image que
l'on a vu c'est Charles de Courson cet
après-midi applaudi autant par les rangs
de la gauche vous voyez qu'il se lèvent
cette gauche pour applaudir le député
liotte et aussi sur la droite de la
droite de l'hémicycle qui est également
se lève à ce moment-là pour applaudir ce
député alors vous allez nous raconter ce
bras de fer autour de cette proposition
de loi entre la majorité et les
oppositions et le symbole serait
terrible pour le gouvernement si demain
cet abrogation était adopté en
commission demain c'est-à-dire le 31 mai
et le 8 juin en séance le gouvernement
espérer qu'un motif Vienne empêcher
l'examen de la proposition de loi c'est
l'article 40 de la Constitution
l'article 40 de quoi s'agit-il
cet article est dispose les le voir que
les propositions et amendements
formulées par les membres du Parlement
ne sont pas recevables lorsque la
rédoption aurait pour conséquence soit
une diminution des ressources publiques
soit la création la gravation d'une
charge publique en clair avec cette
proposition de loi cette ppel c'est
députés vont creuser les déficits or la
Constitution vous le voyez l'interdit
écoutez à ce propos ce matin la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale il y
a LeBron Pivet dans un premier temps
c'est vrai qu'on avait pas beaucoup
entendu elle entendait pas intervenir
dans ce dossier mais ce matin elle a
fait Volt face écouter
j'ai envie de vous dire je trouve ça
dingue je trouve ça dingue parce que
c'est l'application de la loi et de la
règle il n'y a rien de plus démocratique
que d'appliquer la loi il n'y aura pas
de vote sur ce texte on est d'accord
mais il ne doit pas y avoir de débat sur
cet article qui est clairement
anticonstitutionnel ne prend pas ses
responsabilités est-ce que vous en
présence nationale vous prendrez les
vôtres bien sûr donc il n'y aura pas de
vote nous verrons mais en tout cas je
prendrai mes responsabilités c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale et c'est ce
qu'attente de moi mes collègues et
surtout les Français à ce moment-là elle
espérait encore que le président LFI de
la commission des finances déclare la
proposition de loi inconstitutionnelle
en vertu donc de l'article 40 patatras
ce matin et Coquerel convoque la presse
vers 10h30 et il explique toute la
jurisprudence en la matière avant de
conclure qu'il ne il y a pas de problème
avec ce texte selon lui on verra donc si
à la majorité tente d'autres recours
pour empêcher l'examen de la proposition
de loi mais en attendant on a vu tout à
l'heure Elisabeth borne assez énervé
écoutez un extrait on ne défend pas des
institutions à coups de propositions de
loi anticonstitutionnelles on ne ment
pas aux Français en portant avec la plus
grande démagogie un texte dont chacun
sait ici pertinemment qu'il serait
censurés par le Conseil constitutionnel
s'il parvenait au bout de son
cheminement parlementaire alors madame
la Présidente jusqu'au bout nous
défendrons la réalité face à la
démagogie et laquelle la Constitution
face à ceux qui la remettent en cause je
vous remercie et vous nous l'avez dit
Quentin la prochaine étape c'est demain
commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée voilà on va voir ce qui se
passe effectivement demain mais on
rappelle que même si le texte était voté
adopté par les députés il n'a aucune
chance d'être ensuite adopté par le
Sénat qui avait largement voté en faveur
de la réforme des retraites en mars
dernier mais le vote de cette
proposition de loi constituerait une
victoire symbolique importante pour les
oppositions merci beaucoup Quentin et
c'est pour ça que c'est passionnant ce
thème parce qu'il y a à la fois le le
coût politique évidemment le contenu
institutionnel et puis il y a la
question de l'opinion parce que les
Français ont ou non tourné la page de de
cette réforme des retraites aller je
commence qui dit constitution Diane
Charlène bézina forcément est-ce que
quand la présidente de l'Assemblée dit
anticonstitutionnel est-ce que c'est
aussi simple que ça non bien sûr ce qui
est amusant dans ce chose straves dans
ce casse-tête c'est qu'en réalité il y a
plusieurs moments pour cet article 40
c'est-à-dire cet article 40 nous dit
c'est un peu la spécificité de la 5ème
République qui a voulu un peu museler
les initiatives parlementaires sur un
point de vue financier nous dit on n'a
pas le droit d'aggraver une charge
niourdir les dépenser donc le une charge
vous prouve vraiment bien que même pas
une petite charge ne peut être touchée
par vous donc c'est normalement bien
plus dur au niveau des charges ici on a
évidemment une aggravation des charges
mais
Eric Coquerel n'a pas tort de s'appuyer
sur la jurisprudence en tout cas sur la
pratique parlementaire qui fait que pour
les propositions de loi on a toujours
été très souple et président
d'assemblées les présidents de
commission le sont pour permettre à
cette initiative parlementaire de se
développer alors laisse poser la
question aujourd'hui parce que
l'initiative parlementaire est très
développée on a beaucoup plus de
propositions de loi mais on n'a pas
changé cette pratique donc c'est pour ça
qu'il y a El brande pivée d'ailleurs a
été saisie de la question de l'article
40 bien avant qu'on en parle au stade de
la recevabilité de cette proposition
donc avant même qu'elle ne soit
inscrites à l'ordre du jour et il n'y a
pas pour trouver de problème donc elle
arrive un petit peu tardivement dans
cette discussion il y a El Brown privé
puisque elle l'a bien laissé passer une
première fois et là on a le sentiment
qu'elle se réveille un peu tard parce
que évidemment le pouvoir revient au
président de la commission qui déclare
recevable et donc il y a de fortes
chances pour cet article soit discuté
comme il se doit de brandir l'article 40
encore aujourd'hui ou pas alors
aujourd'hui c'est le gouvernement qui le
pourrait n'importe quel député également
c'est l'article 89 alinéa qui a du
Règlement de l'Assemblée qui nous dit
que ça c'est vraiment possible dans tous
les moments de la discussion mais encore
une fois normalement cet examen va à
nouveau échoir à Eric Coquerel donc on
devrait arriver toujours sur la même fin
de nos recevoir un premier tour de table
là-dessus Bruno coquerress est-ce que
les Français sont possible parce que
l'argument principal c'est
aggravation ou diminution des ressources
publiques à la relation d'achat etc
est-ce que les Français sont sensibles à
ça aujourd'hui je crois pas que je suis
la réponse est un peu dans la question
mais bon je rappelle que du sujet au
fond le cœur du sujet c'est beaucoup
plus la question du déni de démocratie
et le sentiment que le gouvernement veut
passer coûte que coûte quel que soit le
moyen
son texte et veut essayer d'empêcher un
débat de parlementaire d'aller jusqu'au
bout parce qu'effectivement ça a été
rappelé si ça allait jusqu'au bout que
l'Assemblée nationale finisse par voter
contre le gouvernement est donc pour
l'abrogation c'est pas un chaos de
démocratique mais c'est un gros hyper
cute on va dire quand même démocratique
pour le gouvernement parce que ça
soulignerait en creux que ça aurait dû
aller jusqu'au bout alors là où ça
devient très compliqué au plan politique
c'est qu'au fond dans un premier temps
l'exécutif souhaitait aller jusqu'au
bout c'est vrai et c'est plein jusqu'au
dernier moment il y a eu pour éviter le
cas
ne veulent pas qu'on aille jusqu'au
fameux article 7 et donc on voit que
tout est très très compliqué dans ce
dans ce débat mais c'est vrai que du
point de vue de qu'est-ce que capte le
l'opinion je parle sur le contrôle de
gale Siemens mais je pense que ce que
capte l'opinion c'est principalement un
gouvernement qui essaye de d'éviter
cette humiliation potentielle du 8 juin
le thème du déni de démocratie il risque
quand même de de coller au basque du du
président est-ce que vous l'analysez
comme ça oui totalement il est déjà très
présent vous avez évoqué s'agissant
d'autres sujets dont on parlera sur la
popularité de l'exécutif est-ce que les
Français commencent à oui commencer un
petit peu à passer à autre chose
c'est-à-dire qu'ils étaient restés
scotchés sur cette question de la
réforme des retraites et jusque là
Emmanuel Macron Lausanne non non mais on
va parler d'autre chose je vais vous je
vais vous faire des cadeaux on va pas il
ne voulait pas longtemps une stratégie
d'occupation de terrain de la part de
d'Emmanuel Macron depuis quelques
semaines qui était assez efficace donc
là je vous vois il y a eu une énorme
erreur une faute politique qui a
consisté au moment de la promulgation de
la loi
au lieu de se dire je vais me taire et
je vais laisser passer le deuil parce
que les gens sont très mécontents de
vouloir multiplier les présences et on
l'a vu dans les territoires se faire
ruer chahuter les casseroles donc il y a
eu une plus qu'une erreur une faute
politique incompréhensible et là on est
en train de répéter une faute parce que
comme ça a été dit par Bruno cotress on
les Français ont le sentiment qu'il y a
eu un déni de démocratie à travers toute
cette épisode de la réforme des
retraites là l'article 47 ans l'article
49.3 etc qu'est-ce que ça coûterait
finalement de ne pas brandir fameuse 40
de laisser le vote se faire quitte à
perdre
qu'est-ce que ça coûte puisqu'à la fin
le texte
des montants la réforme des retraites ne
peut pas passer puisque ça a été très
bien dit au Sénat
de toute manière les Français sont
persuadés que la démocratie a été flouée
dans cette opération dès le départ
politique symbolique peut-être mais
important politique elle est totale
d'ores et déjà c'est déjà le sparadra du
capitaine Haddock quelque part c'est
aussi l'erreur ou la faute d'Emmanuel
Macron de ne pas avoir à un moment donné
un peu mieux assumé un peu plus assumé
le fait que bah oui la démocratie on est
dans un état démocratique il y a rien à
redire à ce sujet mais c'est vrai que
j'ai pas fait ce qu'il fallait j'aurais
dû d'avantages consulter j'aurais pas dû
utiliser il aurait pu faire ça il n'a
donné aucune chance à un moment de
purger vous savez quand il y a un
conflit à un moment donné faut purger là
il se passera ce qui se passera sur cet
article 40 je pense que ce n'est
peut-être même pas si mal pour le
gouvernement que
que ce que ce texte même soit voté c'est
pas leur stratégie pour l'instant
la stratégie assumée jusqu'à maintenant
c'est un marche forcée en plus je
reprends vraiment les mots d'Emmanuel
Macron le 22 mars au 13h cette fameuse
intervention entretien qui a semé le
bazar le lendemain vous vous souvenez
une forte mobilisation dans la rue si
ils assument la marche forcée bah alors
allons-y arrêtons les discussions moi je
pense que la séquence qui fait le plus
de mal c'est la séquence actuelle
l'article 40 partie 40 il y a eu le
Braun pivée qui a pas envie de de le
passer qui refile la poste dès le départ
quand c'était entre les mains de la
présidente de l'Assemblée sur leur
stratégie qui est choisie c'est la
réforme des retraites est derrière nous
on a déjà eu le 49-3 on y va à marche
forcée et finalement cette séquence là
qui évoque ou pas elle fait très mal au
gouvernement parce qu'on voit toutes les
manigances pour éviter justement qui est
ce vote un molette ensuite je vais
retrouver licencie pour savoir ce que
les Français attendent du 8 juin à vous
oui peut-être cette rejoue le même un
brouillot que lors de la réforme des
retraites avec notamment cet article
49.3 c'est à dire qu'en fait l'usage de
la Constitution normalement c'est une
évidence ça se discute en cabinet très
en amont et donc on se demande si ce
gouvernement ne choisit pas d'abord une
danse et puis ensuite change de pied et
ça c'est toujours un petit peu ce qui
lui coûte finalement dans l'opinion donc
on a le sentiment qu'il y a un déni
alors pour moi j'emploierai pas ce mot
déni démocratie dès lors qu'on est dans
des textes constitutionnels mais un déni
d'opinion en tout cas c'est à dire ne
pas réfléchir à l'avance à l'impact
finalement qu'aujourd'hui ces mécanismes
ont sur l'opinion et c'est vrai que
voilà ce vote symbolique va quand même
faire très mal il faut le dire puisque
ça donne l'impression que l'Assemblée
nationale était donc complètement
hostile au projet ce qui redonne
finalement une pièce dans la machine et
une place à la contestation mais
peut-être qu'il aurait fallu le craindre
ou plutôt ou en tout cas au moins jouer
le coup plus tard il sentit ce 8 juin
donc jour ou cette proposition de loi
liotte serait examinée à l'Assemblée
est-ce qu'il y a dans les médias sociaux
réseaux sociaux une attente des
situations français ou alors au
contraire ce qu'ils étaient clairement
en train de passer à autre chose quoi il
faut vraiment revenir un tout petit peu
en arrière je crois que la question de
l'article 40 n'est pas un vrai sujet ça
n'a jamais été un sujet il s'agit de
mettre en face de dépenses il s'agit de
mettre des recettes et il suffit de
trouver des recettes dans la proposition
de loi pour qu'elle soit discutée donc
on est dans une guerre de communication
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on appelle gager
un amendement ou une proposition de loi
c'est une question de communication
aujourd'hui
dans cette communication là on a eu le
mois dernier jusqu'au mois dernier une
présence
inégalée non seulement du président de
la République mais également des
gouvernements dans les médias sociaux ce
qu'on constate aujourd'hui c'est
un retour en arrière une sorte de chute
une correction des volumes de présente
des de présence des chiffres de 60% de
70% etc ça il faut l'interpréter est-ce
que ça signifie et notamment pour le 8
juin prochain
que les Français sont passés à autre
chose
ce qu'on la manière dont on peut dire
d'interpréter c'est que il y a un
mouvement de fonds plus important et
brutal de désintérêt pour les affaires
politiques un peu comme si on avait vécu
une période alors démocratie je sais pas
mais en tout cas refus de dialogue c'est
sûr refus de bouger c'est sûr et du coup
ça rend tout débat sur les sujets à la
fois vingt et stériles un peu comme s'il
est les Français étaient sortis KO et
finalement ne font plus que très très
peu références à l'ensemble du personnel
politique majorité comme opposition il
faut pas l'interpréter comme un signal
forcément positif ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui c'est un une perte de
confiance une stérilisation du débat
politique et ça peut vouloir dire quand
même que sur le vrai sujet qui était le
désaccord entre les Français le
gouvernement sur la retraite peut-être
que le feu groove
[Musique]
les jours le troisième et dernier
chapitre de ce débat 100% en politique
la loi immigration Emilie pour l'instant
les lignes ne bougent pas trop on va
dire entre la majorité et le parti LR
les République oui on a d'un côté chiche
monsieur le Président de l'autre chiche
travaillant ensemble mais chacun a beau
utiliser ce mot c'est pas gagné pour
autant et le rapprochement traduit en
loi entre les pensées des républicains
et celle de la majorité sur le thème de
l'immigration c'est pas encore
d'actualité alors je vous rappelle le
contexte depuis plusieurs mois Gérald
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur tente
de pousser l'idée d'une loi sur
l'immigration une énième loi du genre
concertation repoussée perspective de
saucissonnage ça serait plusieurs textes
pour augmenter le potentiel de vente de
vote là dessus c'est intéressant les
deux un coup à droite un coup à gauche
puis finalement on repart sur une loi
entière mais qui est repoussée et qui
finalement est reprise bref
c'est les hésitations désormais connues
de la majorité qui peinent à faire
passer ses lois par manque de majorité
parlementaire et à faire appliquer ce en
même temps qui est très attractif sur le
papier finalement le projet de loi de
Darmanin est en préparation avec un
texte annoncé dissil l'été et une
adoption d'ici la fin de l'année enfin
ça c'est le concept théorique surtout on
parlait de négociation que donc les
républicains ont dégainé leur propre
texte au pluriel alors oui et on a deux
textes pour le prix d'un une proposition
de loi qui contient des mesures assez
radicales quotas de migrants
durcissement du regroupement familial
droit du sol et une autre qui permet de
s'exonérer des règles juridiques
européennes et internationales en
matière d'immigration chiche monsieur le
Président donc c'est donc écrit
fièrement dans le JDD la semaine
dernière le trio de choc des
républicains Éric Ciotti Bruno
Retailleau et Olivier marlex un chiche
auquel Darmanin a répondu ce week-end
dans le Parisien chiche travaillons
ensemble mais si chacun veut bien
essayer de faire un ou en tout cas dans
les médias et notamment Darmanin sur
l'aide médicale d'État le
conditionnement des visas ou les mineurs
les lignes rouges de chaque partie ne
bouge pas alors quels sont ces lignes
rouges dans les détails alors du côté de
la majorité impossible imposable
impensable même de déroger aux règles
européennes pour Darmanin ça serait
l'équivalent d'un frexit migratoire à
droite impossible de succomber un en
même temps mou qui permettrait à des
immigrer illégaux d'obtenir des titres
de séjour pour les métiers en tension la
preuve de ce dialogue difficile avec
Olivier Marleix ce matin sur RTL
ou remettre sur la table et c'est pas le
petit bricolage ou le petit marchandage
que nous propose monsieur Darmanin qui y
répondra donc lui il parle de petits
bricolage et c'est sans compter aussi
sur les divergences qui règnent au sein
de la majorité dans ce jeu les
républicains à l'image de Bruno
retaillod c'était ce matin aussi sur
France Inter cette fois-ci ce que
j'observe c'est une division profonde de
la majorité à chaque fois que Gérald
Darmanin fait un pas vers nous par
exemple sur l'aide médicale d'État qu'on
veut transformer en aide médicale
d'urgence comme la plupart des pays
européens et bien sa propre majorité
François et d'autres ministres dit stop
surtout pas alors difficile de voir
comment on va travailler ensemble dans
ce contexte le gouvernement finalement
il est pris dans un diname intenable
cédé aux sirènes radicales de la droite
pour faire passer le texte ou alors
irrésite St quitte à utiliser le
redoutable 49-3 ce qui pourrait en plus
provoquer une motion de censure de la
part des républicains alors face à ce
marasme législatif ou même prélégislatif
je continue à poser une question
pourquoi cette entêtement à faire passer
une loi dans le sujet ne permet pas
d'obtenir la majorité au Parlement mais
surtout un sujet qui ne correspond pas
totalement aux préoccupations majeures
des Français à l'heure actuelle bien sûr
le thème reste d'importance et il parle
notamment aux électeurs de droite et
d'extrême droite mais il est bien loin
derrière les problématiques d'inflation
62% des Français le site je dis ça
soleil attentif je pense que Gaëlle aura
quelques chiffres à valider oui pour la
santé on est à 54% pour la protection
sociale on est à 34% finalement
l'immigration n'intervient qu'en sixième
position avec seulement 25% des
suffrages
votre analyse sur effectivement la place
de l'immigration les attentes des
différents groupes politiques enfin des
sympathisants des Français en fonction
de leur sympathie politique j'y arrive
sur ce thème de l'immigration alors je
rejoins Émilie on peut se poser la
question effectivement elle a rappelé
les chiffres de notre sondage pour pour
Le Figaro de la semaine dernière mais
français ils ont une pensée complexe
comme dirait Emmanuel Macron sur la
question de l'immigration parce que on
avait présenté notamment en deux
tableaux on voyait le résultat auprès
des Français et on voit l'immigration
s'effondrer d'ailleurs il y a une autre
paramètre qui s'effondre une autre
priorité qui était la priorité majeure
qu'on suit depuis 25 ou 30 ans le
chômage ça n'existe plus en terme de
priorité pour les gens à partir du
moment où il est en voie de résolution
le problème n'existe plus c'est quand
même intéressant d'avoir l'esprit donc
l'immigration c'est pas une priorité
majeure mais les gens sont de plus en
plus durs sur le sujet il y a une
droitisation qui fait qu'aujourd'hui les
trois quarts des Français considèrent
qu'il y a trop d'immigrés en France
c'est une phrase qu'on met avec des
guillemets qu'on teste dans le temps
long depuis des décennies et à l'époque
quand vous étiez sympathisant de gauche
c'était juste impensable de dire ça il y
avait pas de sympathisant de gauche qui
disait il y a trop d'immigrés en France
aujourd'hui il y a un consensus dans
l'opinion pour dire oui il y a trop
d'immigrés en France donc l'opinion
publique elle est pas spécialement de
mendeuse de sujets sur l'immigration
c'est un sujet clivant malgré tout sur
les dimensions que vous souhaitez
activer mais c'est un sujet qui séduit
beaucoup les lecteurs de droite quand on
regarde ce que nous disent les des
petits endroits c'est la deuxième
priorité pour les sympathisants de
droite et par contre pour boucler la
boucle comme l'opinion elle est elle est
française sont complexes sur le sujet
ils sont à la fois d'accord avec chacune
des principales propositions que nous
avons testé proposées par LR qui vont
chercher à durcir les lois sur
l'immigration toutes celles qu'on a
testé il y a plus de 60 % d'adhésion
mais en même temps ils sont d'accord les
Français avec des propositions plus cool
plus soft qui sont notamment portés par
Renaissance et par le gouvernement ou
par Olivier du socle sur le fait de
donner la possibilité aux demandeurs
d'asile de travailler dès le dépôt de
leur demande de régularisation on a six
Français sur 10 qui sont favorables et
si Français sur 10 aussi qui nous dit on
est favorable à la création d'un titre
de séjour pour les travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers sous tension
donc exactement le sujet qui fait
polémique entre LR et Renaissance et je
rejoins Émilie sur un point aussi c'est
que dans des périodes où on a une telle
conflictualité sociale dans le pays à
cause de la réforme des retraites c'est
quand même un petit peu étonnant même si
on brille on essaye de draguer électorat
de droite d'aller chercher un sujet qui
est un sujet aussiruptif sur le plan des
manifestants notamment Bruno cotressko
comment effectivement vous l'analysez ça
pour rebondir ce que vient de dire
Gaëlle et puis est-ce qu'on peut croire
à des vrais négociations entre entre
mises à l'intérieur et les cadors de LR
oui une logique quand même du côté du
gouvernement de maître de maître ce
sujet qui est quand même effectivement à
la fois son problème fondamental qui est
l'absence de majorité absolue la
recherche désespérée d'un accord tacite
avec les républicains
et la raison pour laquelle ils insistent
c'est que c'est quand même on voit une
situation qui devient de plus en plus
difficile à tenir pour pour l'exécutif
qui dossier après dossier maintenant
rencontre des difficultés on voit qu'il
est toujours pas sorti du dossier de la
réforme des retraites de de ce fait donc
il y a quand même il y a quand même une
logique il y a quand même une
perspective
électoral qui arrive avec des élections
européennes qui pour le moment s'annonce
peut-être pas si mauvais ce que ça pour
le rassemblement national compte tenu à
la fois de de l'état de l'opinion
contenu du sujet etc il est pas étonnant
du tout de voir que du côté de Darmanin
on fixe la limite effectivement sur la
question des règles européennes parce
qu'on essaye de capter cet écart de
centre droit qui est globalement on va
dire favorable à l'intégration
européenne tout en étant inquiet des
conséquences migratoires donc voilà il y
a quand même il y a quand même une forme
de logique après je vous rejoins
effectivement
on se demande effectivement où est-ce
qu'il y avait urgence d'autant qu'il y
ait énormément de législation sur la
question de l'immigration et puis après
il y a une fascinante tendance des
politiques à semer d'embûches leur
propre chemin
je suis en avaient pas suffisamment
grâce aux autres
études électorales par un maître de la
science électorale qui avait écrit un
livre que le meilleur père dans lequel
il racontait les efforts désespérés que
faisaient les gouvernants pour essayer
de perdre les élections
de l'a dit intéressante puisqu'il y a
deux textes des peurs là sur la
stratégie DLR il y a deux textes déposés
par les républicains et notamment une
loi constitutionnelle pour s'émanciper
des règles européennes est-ce que c'est
réaliste ça alors
réaliste de toute façon la Constitution
est un outil juridique aux mains d'une
majorité politique qui peut donc y
inscrire absolument ce qu'elle veut la
seule chose c'est la question de
l'efficience c'est de l'efficacité et
inscrire dans notre Constitution que
nous souhaitons déroger à des traités
auxquels nous sommes partis et que nous
avons signé ne servira absolument à rien
pour déroger à ces traités puisque la
seule chose qu'on peut faire pour un
menuiser les obligations internationales
c'est d'aller les négocier à
l'international donc on évoque souvent
l'exemple danois par exemple le Danemark
peut sortir de certaines des règles
d'asile et donc de
européenne parce que le Danemark depuis
son refus du traité Maastricht en 92 a
négocié auprès de la Commission
européenne ce qu'on appelle des clauses
d'opting out c'est à dire des clauses de
sortie des politiques européennes
qui suffirait il faudrait le négocier je
vous comprends bien au niveau européen
au niveau européen et aujourd'hui la
France qui le ferait 60 ans plus tard
paraîtrait quand même un petit peu
étrange quand on négocie des clauses de
sortie du traité c'est généralement au
moment où le signe donc la rigueur on
aurait pu avoir une force de proposition
en 2005 quand on a une non au référendum
mais on ne l'a pas utilisé autre point
est-ce que c'est finalement si
antitétique d'utiliser la loi
immigration comme un ressort de la
majorité simple moi j'en suis pas sûr
parce que j'ai l'impression c'est un peu
la dernière cartouche si la majorité
n'arrive pas à aller travailler sur le
terrain des LR qui est le seul groupe
avec lequel la majorité stéréo comme le
disait Guy Carcassonne en 88 pourrait
fonctionner que reste-t-il à cette
majorité je rappelle qu'on est dans la
fameuse période des 100 jours ou
Emmanuel Macron veut tester Elisabeth
borne sur ses majorités élargies donc si
Elisabeth borne n'y parvient pas sur les
sujets économiques ou normalement les LR
avaient une ligne très fixe et sur les
sujets migratoires ou normalement les LR
ont une ligne très fixe a priori ça veut
dire qu'il ne pourra pas y avoir de
majorité élargie pendant les quatre
prochaines années donc je crois que
c'est un peu une recherche de la
dernière chance mais c'est très à
l'avantage du groupe LR qui du coup peut
jouer la fine bouche et surtout donner
un petit peu ses conditions rappelons
quand même que la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle en tant que tel elle
va être un peu touché quand même à
adopter je pense tout dernier mot
dernier mot c'est à l'avantage du groupe
LR sur le plan du Parlement c'est à
l'avantage du rassemblement national et
de Marine Le Pen sur le plan politique
parce que le dernier inconvénient allait
sur un territoire ou un autre est jugé à
tort ou à raison plus fort ou
appréhender territoire avant vous c'est
c'est la règle du jeu de qui avait fait
monter le rassemblement national le
Front national lors de précédent scrutin
et Marine Le Pen est celle qui sont sur
le mieux dans notre baromètre politique
elle n'a jamais été aussi haute et ben
voilà on termine là-dessus merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce premier débat à
bientôt sur public